also ein noch nicht da gewesenes
spielzeuge konzipieren das sind sie ganz
geniale magneten sinken sind richtig
cool aber wenig wenigen kugler gerade wo
ich habe ein patent anhalt bezahlt wir
haben uns die markenrechte max lipp
sicher ist 5000 euro denn investiert hat
im brucker patentamt material alles
mögliche in deutschland handarbeit wenn
wir uns jetzt bei der größten stadt seht
ihr das jahrtausend unterstützt
errechnet dann können ja selbst über den
link in der video beschreibung
unterstützen und euch jetzt 1 bestehen
wir haben jetzt das ziel
15.000 euro zusammen wie geil ist denn
dieses spielplatz gebaut hat das könnte
wirklich mittels peter zeit erfüllt
werden
und was soll ich sagen dieses geld ist
mittlerweile weg und das mit dem
werksklub läuft anders als geplant und
das obwohl ich noch vor einer woche
dachte die sind so gut wie fertig
jetzt ist es also soweit das ist jetzt
weiß ich wie das ergebnis von über einem
halben jahr arbeit
ba hat aber einfach so drin liegt das
ist es hier das ist richtig geil ich
muss zugeben ich habe schon bilder davon
gesehen aber den er fühlt sich auch
einmal richtig geil an das ist actually
einmal richtig geil werden auch die
nähte sind komplett insane wer ein
bisschen angst dass sie nicht her
einfach billig wirken aber das sieht
richtig geisteskrankheit aus mega massiv
wir haben der metallkern okay so
das ist auch das ist hier um so mattes
aber die der schriftzug er so glänzt sie
jetzt ist wirklich so dass man verkauft
sondern
schon also ja
das sieht jetzt so aus wie es meinem
laden warum also sind jan kriegst das
ist übel geil das richtig krank mir
fällt damit auch einfach so ein
riesenstein vom herzen weil jetzt diese
ganze zeit es gibt so viele leute die
das teil hat einfach schon gekauft haben
er ist einfach perfekt die balance in
salt lake city das war die idee mit dem
eisen kennen hier echt ohne witz im wald
komplett geil einfach einfach krank
denn die ganz damals in der iss verfügt
jetzt alle hast ja mitgemacht habe mir
ein bisschen kantig und heftig hell fast
voll gewesen mit der er mit dem druck
der schrift hier drin hast voll cool
weil ich kannte das ja auch noch so
einen diesen dingen hier die druck und
da sei es immer
ja genau
kann ich mal einen krieg nicht mehr
muss wieder haben jetzt
schon verrückt sie als jemand der das ja
von anfang an mit beobachten durfte so
aber das hat sie noch viel mehr der box
und schauen dass man ich freue mich wie
ein kleines kind montage richtung des
kerns beachten hahaha ist das geil nur
schade dass man die niemals sehen wird
das kommt dann einfach hier rein und
da steckt dann auch so sieht merkel von
hinaus hier sind sie als magneten satz
kugellager als noch so drin also noch
ganz viele karten und aufseher an einem
blau und einmal noch in grün dahin kann
ich jetzt auch mal gerne zeigen wie man
so ein merkel zusammenbaut
[Musik]
schritt eins wäre es dann den metallkern
einzulegen so sieht merkt wie von innen
aus und die sind alle identisch das
heißt es ist alles ein und dasselbe ding
und wenn man das eine umdreht da passen
wir diese nicht einfach genau
aufeinander und könnten jetzt
zusammengestellt werden da man schon im
griff gehen ja die flotte sein mal fest
drücken und jetzt wieder richtig
spannend dass nämlich der
krisenmechanismus unternehmen jetzt hier
einmal dieses verbindungsstück mädels
von hinten durch den magnet halte und
dann rastet ihr dieses eine kleine weiße
stück hier im magnet halter ein die
andere seite den weißen wänden kommen
dann in die kugellager kappe
reinschieben und dann kommt das
kugellager und schon ist der zeit hier
fest mit genau den richtigen abstand der
schnur jo da muss man nur noch den
magneten reinstecken zack das ist so
fest dass es nicht mehr rauskommt ganze
noch ein zweites mal und
zack das sitzt ganz wichtig der magnet
muss natürlich jetzt richtig gut drauf
sein stoßen sind nicht ab und das will
natürlich keiner und fertig ist der
markt aber das ist so geil also besten
gewissens kann man das ding jetzt
einfach an 200.000 wurde wann schicken
dollar kann man nicht darf man nicht
dass es kein fertiges produkt erkennt
dass auch von zum beispiel lego das
nicht von kindern unter drei benutzt
werden darf da ist von ihnen verschluckt
werden könnte wir wussten schon von
anfang an dass produkte und vor allem
spielzeuge die an kinder unter 14
verkauft werden besondere richtlinien
einhalten müssen wie sehr sind in der
din e71 festgehalten mehrere hundert
seiten die mehrere hundert euro kosten
in denen haargenau die theres was unter
welchen umständen in welche art von
spielzeug baut sein darf wie groß und
auch wie stabil ein bauteil sein muss
und auch mit welchen extrem teuren
messverfahren und laboruntersuchungen
das geprüft werden muss so viel selbst
die 80 bzw nach abzügen 58.000 euro von
kickstarter neben einen anderen ausgaben
nicht reichen würden aber merklich ihn
geplant haben war ja gar nicht gedacht
für unbeaufsichtigte kleinkinder lego
steine essen als wären es cornflakes
sondern bringe für jugendliche und
erwachsene dem einer krassen
herausforderung ihrer geschichte und vor
allem ihre geduld ring in richtung also
glück gehabt dachten wir zumindest denn
diese europäische norm gilt für alle
erzeugnisse die dazu bestimmt oder
gestaltet sind von kindern unter 14
jahren verwendet zu werden wie hier bei
den blades könnte dann auf dem mac clip
ab 14 drauf stehen und jeder und vor
allem die eltern müssen bescheid das ist
nichts für kleine kinder alles gut 2
ist es nicht also zumindest womöglich
nicht denn nochmal zurück zum
offiziellen text diese europäische norm
gilt für alle erzeugnisse die dazu
bestimmt oder gestaltet sind von kindern
unter 14 jahren verwendet zu werden und
nun die frage wer legt fest wo zu etwas
gestaltet wurde derjenige der es
gestaltet hat oder
derjenige das gestaltet hat oder
womöglich etwas naiv weil viel mehr
bedeutet als dass aufsichtsperson allein
aufgrund der funktion abmessungen und
eigenschaften eines spielzeugs
vernünftigerweise einschätzen können für
welche altersgruppe es bestimmt ist und
deswegen um wirklich auf der sicheren
seite zu sein müssen wir diese ganzen
richtlinien einhalten einmal das grund
werk und dann noch 3 2 und teil 3
passiert zum beispiel wurde im februar
geupdatet und das hier im juni vor zwei
monaten was natürlich auch nicht mal als
machen wenn sie so was so schnell ändern
um dieses ganze ding mal grob
zusammenzufassen das schwierigste sind
eigentlich kleine teile magneten und
schnüre das schlimmste was erfinden
könnte sind kleine magneten an schnüren
und dann habe ich mit dem mac flip
verschiedenste fest durchgeführt die man
eben bestehen muss für unter 14-jährige
mit das wichtigste thema sind hierbei
kleinteile ohne verschluckbare
kleinteile ist alles quasi kein problem
wenn aber ein einzelteil nun vollständig
in diesem test zylinder passt dann
wird's kompliziert
[Musik]
und es damit wird es kompliziert und wir
kommen zur schlag prüfung das spielzeug
wird auf einer ebenen auflagefläche
angeordnet aus zehn zentimeter höhe wird
ein gewicht stück mit einem kilo auf das
spielzeug fallen gelassen
es ist festzustellen ob kleine teile
zugänglich geworden sind
weiter geht es mit der fall prüfung aus
einer höhe von 85 zentimetern wird das
spielzeug fünf mal fallen gelassen
[Musik]
es ist festzustellen ob kleine teile
zugänglich geworden sind das sei auch
gut aus zur prüfung das spielzeug wird
befestigt dann mit hilfe einer klemme
oder anderen spannvorrichtungen eine
kraft auf das einzelteil aufgebracht was
denkt ihr was diese teile hier aushalten
müssen das gewicht von einer
plastikflasche halben kilo zwei flaschen
zwei flaschen sechs flaschen
12 es sind tatsächlich 18 flaschen
spricht neun kilo was dieses teil hier
aushalten muss
[Musik]
es ist festzustellen ob sich das einzel
teil gelöst hat
es an drei kilo das ist tot rief das
hier dass man jetzt an dieses kleine
teil hängen könnte und das würde
aushalten aber mehr eben nicht die also
die werkzeuge diese metall dinge die
insgesamt über 20.000 euro kosten
logischerweise nicht einfach sein kann
die sind schon die existieren schon die
sind halt schon so diese vier interessen
gefragt was jetzt der plan ist und
meine antwort war es gibt kann man
das alles also diese ganze verzögerung
tut mir schrecklich leid war natürlich
für die über 2000 menschen die hart
arbeitet das geld investiert haben um
den mac apps ermöglichen und jetzt immer
noch zur ausfahrt ist ganz ehrlich das
bricht mir das herz mittlerweile gibt es
aber im plan wie es weitergeht auch mit
der finanzierung und der lautet wie
folgt alle wichtigen teile werden
abgeändert und stabiler gemacht dass
hier ist bereits die neu schnur die mit
abstand stabil genug ist dieser steckt
ob sie für das kugellager wird von drei
auf fünf millimeter dicker gemacht und
beinhaltet dann 28 mal so viel tragen
das material das kugellager wird von
vier auf fünf millimeter verlängert für
mehr haftung die wanddicke der lager
kappen wird fast verdoppelt dadurch
würde sich das design äußerlich kaum
verändern aber die stabilität
hoffentlich sich verdreifacht wenn das
dann fertig ist werden nach nec philips
zum tüv geschickt für eine mechanische
und chemische untersuchung wofür uns der
tüv sogar schon ein angebot gemacht hat
und wenn der das ok gibt kann es
losgehen und der maple bis sogar
tauglich für kinder unter 14 jahren
diese ganzen änderungen einen spritzguss
vor mechanische und chemische prüfungen
beim trip von denen wir eigentlich
dachten dass wir sie gar nicht brauchen
sowie beratung von experten kostet
natürlich extrem viel geld wofür ich
selbst gerade steht und dass ich
persönlich finanzieren werde einerseits
natürlich weil ich die verantwortung
trage und hier kein supporter hängen
gelassen wird diese worte werden nun
übrigens hier links namentlich alle
eingeblendet aber wie gesagt nicht nur
will ich die leute hier nicht hängen
lassen sondern der weg hier bist
wirklich extrem geil die verpackung die
anleitung das generelle konzept und die
hunderten kleinen genialen ideen die die
community sebastian matthias von der
spritzguss firma und ich hier mit
einfließen lassen haben überzeugen mich
so hart dass das für mich ehrlich gesagt
gar keine frage ist ich bin überzeugt
davon dass jeder der das ding aus
partner in den händen halten wird
absolut begeistert davon sein wird und
dafür dass das so schnell wie möglich
passiert in das tier und kämpfe ich
gerne nicht recht von dem kompletten
auftritt vom produkt bis hin zur
anleitung bis zur website und zwar so
sehr dass sie auch die domain mag flip
punkt kommt für fast 5000 euro gekauft
habt treffen geldes aber was natürlich
auch super wichtig ist ich finde das ist
etwas einzigartiges was wir durchziehen
und wenn ich daran denke dass antrag des
releases zweieinhalbtausend mike
phillips von den ganzen support und hier
ausgepackt werden und wenn ich daran
denke dass er merkt irgendwann ganz
normal von gebe einfach gekauft werden
kann und wir kommen der neue tricks
erfindet und ihnen namen gibt dann
motiviert mich das alles dafür zu geben
sie wasser noch nicht aber in der jeden
tag daran ab sofort kann ich auch
endlich wieder regelmäßig updates und
update videos dazu machen in den letzten
wochen waren uns damals die
kommunikation angeht aus rechtlichen
gründen leider die hände so ein bisschen
gebunden was mir extrem leute und eines
dieser updates werden zum beispiel die
600 standfüße die wir für einige das
sofort gedruckt haben und ein weiteres
update nehme ich die anleitung zu dem
ding und die aktuelle verpackung zeigen
findet ihr jetzt gerade aktuell auf
meinem zweiten kanal über den link in
der beschreibung die verzögerung liegt
aber zum teil auch daran dass ich möchte
dass das ding perfekt ist die haben
folgendes den kickstarter supporter
nirgendwo versprochen aber ich habe
entschieden dass jeder mag flip einen
schweren metallkern verpasst bekommt
damit er sich wertiger anfühlt uns
perfekt balanciert ist auch wenn es noch
teurer für mich ist es ist nun wie
gesagt nicht so dass von den knapp
60.000 euro von kickstarter etwas für
mich über bleibt würde ich leg sogar
noch mal sehr viel grau aber wer weiß
vielleicht findet er merkt ja sogar an
bei den leuten die mich persönlich
überhaupt gar nicht kennen und das
abenteuer nimmt komplett bild der
ausmaße an wann der markt für jeden
verfügbar ist kann ich heute nicht sagen
das ganze thema ist nicht ohne grund so
explodiert und dieser grund ist da ist
das ganze ehrlich gesagt komplett
verrückt ist wie verrückt war mir
anfangs echt nicht klar aber wenn es mir
egal gewesen wäre dann wären wir wohl
nie so weit gekommen wie jetzt und
nachdem es kurzzeitig echt dunkle
ausgesehen hat habe ich mittlerweile
überhaupt keine zweifel mehr und
deswegen kann ich eigentlich hoffen dass
ihr mir dafür zeit und noch ein bisschen
geduld aber mehr eben auch vertraut wenn
ich sage dass wir uns komplett den arsch
aufreißen würde alle sofort mit bis zu
50 euro hatte eben eingeblendet gesehen
das waren jetzt fast 2000 und jetzt das
heftigste die namentliche nennung von
165 menschen die tatsächlich nur 9 90
euro oder mehr beigetragen haben
angefangen mit denen die sogar 250 euro
investiert haben vielen vielen dank an
valentin moloko thomas simon hunger
class dörfling tobias haardt timon
müller die arag rasmussen merlin reiter
kameeta randy brain power group david
kästle adrian felix gabriel steffen
eisentraut matthias jan schäfer carsten
b peter jenny sebastian emsen huber
markus baur jonathan willem nochmal
thomas patrick rüther pascal uckermark
schreibt und christoph gärtner dass das
zu finden werden hätte ich niemals
gedacht die 250 euro waren ehrlich
gesagt eher eine schnapsidee dass das
jemand bereit ist als tragen
hätte ich nicht gedacht und jetzt riesen
dank an die 130 menschen die 99 euro
beigetragen haben vielen vielen dank an
ddm lukas katrina rubys der curry
matthias klasen häcki handtücher
matthias strauß niklas dommuseum
grossenbacher antonio tim ebert marc
huber jene für hensel gibt denn es an
jan philipp pascal schwarz thomas
kollerer verletzt dennis brode andreas
timo wiegers mein steuerberater justin
jakob penndorf story mails blut daniel
becker knox tobias paul vidic tobias
laufersweiler michael dietl der lappen
nils schablitzki hört oder kurt leonhard
sandro geliehen hub andreas klee blume
dominik marx grüßen jona schürings oder
in der echte falk jonas alexander von
holz
sascha bush david bernhard kilian thoma
wie wie daniel christopher stein jemand
der einfach nur tee als namen gegeben
hat gartners maximilian heilig gabriel
hilf elias planer laura marcel ganz an
dreas natalie riehl timo brückner syrien
mattes anton paul breithecker der max
jean-marc everding alexander fetzer
mattes wolf jan demut gott kanzler
pascal neuenschwander luca berthold wenn
ikea david konzentrieren schäfers groß
marie böttcher justin robin aljoscha
nass florian riese download nils 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 0 daniel graf hering könig
andreas wünsche pascal sebastian rose
kevin boneberger max alexander dannecker
leon springer marc brehm frances gladys
lukas meiswinkel fabian soko lokalen
bauern natalie rebholz arnold fand die
erste herren stefan ullenboom tobias
tasci elias baumgartner jemal janosch
franziska hempel hat nie web data flitz
people ja nix 09 nick weber colin poole
ascii marcel und zu guter letzt julian
lena dankeschön das war jetzt eine
extrem lange liste und alle leute die
jetzt hier quasi die namentlich genannt
oder in textform vorgekommen sind all
die haben das möglich gemacht ich freue
mich jetzt richtig wieder vollgas geben
zu können mit den ganzen videos zum
thema merkel hat jetzt wo das alles
geklärt ist jetzt wo viele wichtige
dinge im hintergrund geklärt sind und
die liste mit videos die ihn auch auf
einem zweiten machen muss zum thema mac
grip ist ellenlang fast so lang wie die
liste an supportern wenn euch das
interessiert schaut gerade von zwei
knapp vorbei da gibt es ein video wo ich
die verpackung anschaue und die
anleitung von max lipp ansonsten
abonniert gerne diesen kanal wenn ihr
alles was ich so mache einfach verfolgen
möchte und dann sehen uns demnächst mal
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]